hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream in 20 Tagen geht sie los die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar eine
WM deren Vergabe durch korrupte FIFA
Mitglieder erfolgte eine WM bei der
viele Menschen gestorben sind weil sie
beim Bau der Stadien unter
menschenunwürdigung unwürdigen
Bedingungen arbeiten mussten und eine WM
in einem Land das Menschen ihre
Sexualität abspricht und sie dafür ins
Gefängnis steckt
wie oben gehen mit dieser WM
boykottieren ja oder nein wie umgehen
mit Katha als Land insgesamt was
verändert diese WM das ist unsere Frage
heute und darüber diskutieren wir heute
mit Alexander Koch er ist ehemaliger
FIFA Kommunikationschef und mit Wenzel
Michalski Direktor von human right
Swatch was beschäftigt euch zu diesem
Thema welche Fragen welche Meinungen
habt ihr schreibt ihr uns gerne direkt
in die Chats oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de wir versuchen so viel
wie möglich in die Diskussion später mit
einzubauen
da sind sicher dann auch Fragen dabei
mit denen heute bundesinnenministerin
Nancy fazer gemeinsam mit Vertretern des
Deutschen Fußball-Bundes in das
Gastgeberland katter gereist ist seit
heute Nachmittag wir haben es im Blick
bei ihrer Ankunft ist sie vor Ort und
sie hat jetzt schon ein erstes Fazit
gezogen es gab ein erstes Gespräch zum
Thema Menschenrechte und in dieses erste
Fazit zu dieser Reise da hören wir jetzt
gemeinsam rein das wurde hervorgehoben
dass sehr gute Gesetze auf den Weg
gebracht wurden in den letzten Jahren
und das ist jetzt darum ginge diese
natürlich auch mit Leben zu füllen aber
es ist
doch so dass die meisten einfach gesagt
haben es gibt Verbesserungen und die
sind gut und auch auf die Frage ob das
nach
der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft weitergeht
wurde eindeutig gesagt ja sie seien da
sehr zuversichtlich dass es auch weiter
fortgeführt wird so dass ich jetzt ein
ich sag mal ersten ganz positiven
Einblick von dieser wirklich guten
Diskussionen mitgenommen haben
soweit bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
nach ihrer Ankunft heute unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent Thomas Reichert
der ist auch vor Ort in door er
begleitet das Treffen von Phaser dort
vor Ort Thomas auf den ersten Blick
ziemlich früh für so ein erstes
Statement direkt so nach der Ankunft
oder
ist schon ziemlich früh Phaser hat sich
eigentlich viel vorgenommen sie hat
gesagt sie will sich selbst ein Bild
davon machen was hier passiert ist und
welche Situation in Sachen
Menschenrechte verbandarbeit aber auch
Rechte für lgbq-gemeinschaften ist hier
gibt und wie das wobei der WM dann
aussehen wird ich glaube wahrscheinlich
die erste Fazit das kann man schon
insofern schließen als Phaser überhaupt
hierher gekommen ist aus ihrem Umfeld
haben wir erfahren dass sie ein bisschen
zum Freitag noch gar nicht sicher war ob
sie wirklich fahren würde sie hatte ein
paar Tage zuvor in einem Interview
gesagt dass sie die Vergabe nicht gut
findet sie hat gesagt es wäre besser
gewesen wenn die werden nicht dorthin
vergeben worden wäre das hat großen
Aufruhr hier in Katar gesorgt und der
deutsche Botschafter würde einbestellt
von nasty fazer wurde eine Erklärung
gefordert die sie nicht geben wollte und
wegen der sie vermutlich dann auch nicht
gefahren wäre über das Wochenende haben
sich laufen weil die Wellen so weit
gelegt dass sie gefahren ist aber
immerhin die Menschenrechtsbeauftragte
der Bundesregierung Arnsberg die ist zum
Beispiel zu Hause geb also Nancy faces
ist erstmal hier sie hat gesagt sie wird
sich von der Sache jetzt erstmal nicht
weiter einschüchtern lassen aber klar
ist und das spüren wir ehrlich gesagt
auch hier in der Art wie die hier
arbeiten können
Qatar ist schon aufgeregt und angespannt
weil sie den Eindruck haben dass sie im
Scheinwerfer nicht stehen mit ihren
Problemen bei den Menschenrechten aber
andererseits aus ihrer Sicht jedenfalls
auch ungerechtfertigt im Mensch eben
scheinbar völlig stehen weil sie sagen
wir haben einige Reformen angeschoben
wenn sie face hat es gerade im O-Ton
gesagt und ihr seid im Vergleich zu
anderen Golfstaaten mit uns ungewöhnlich
streng wenn Sie viel seit zwei Tage um
sich ein Bild zu machen nachdem was wir
bis jetzt gesehen habe haben sind das
fast zu wenig Tage Thomas ganz kurz ich
sehe gerade ganz viele Kommentare im
Chat die Fragen nach der Verspätung
warum unser Stream ein bisschen später
gestartet ist dafür Entschuldigung wir
hatten technische Probleme zu Beginn und
auch du du bist etwas dumpf zu hören
aber also man versteht dich ich hoffe
liebe Userinnen und User das auch ihr du
hast verstehen konntet falls nicht
schreibt das gerne rein ansonsten machen
wir weiter Thomas du hast viele Punkte
schon thematisiert du hast auch
angesprochen und bestätigt das auch Du
den Eindruck hast dass natürlich ein
frühes zwischen Fazit ist und dieses
Fazit auch die Art und Weise stehen
natürlich auch im Kontrast zu den
Aussagen die Phaser im Vorfeld getätigt
hat du hast es gesagt sie hat gesagt es
gäbe Kriterien wie Einhaltung von
Menschenrechten oder nachhaltig
krankheitsprinzipien an die sich einfach
gehalten werden muss wie schätzt du das
ein wie kann denn dieser schnelle Törn
jetzt so zustande kommen bei ihr
ich glaube dass in Wahrheit ein Spagat
gerade macht wie übrigens auch der
DFB-Präsident Bert Neuendorf der Mitte
hierher gereist ist auf der einen Seite
die die Kritikpunkte anzusprechen
gegenüber der Regierung von Katar sich
nicht im Mond verbieten zu lassen
sondern klar und deutlich auch die
Erwartungen an Katar zu formulieren
übrigens auch an die FIFA und zu sagen
wir warten von euch in Zukunft bei der
Vergabe von Sport Großereignissen wie
eine Fußball-WM das bestimmte Vergabe
Richtlinien wie Menschenrechte wie
Nachhaltigkeit eingehalten werden das
ist die eine Seite Spagats und die
andere ist dass sie natürlich sich
selbst ein Bild machen will und in
dieser Hinsicht auch den Kataris eine
Chance geben will zu zeigen welche
Reform sie tatsächlich angestrengt haben
die nachhaltig wie realistisch die sind
und ob die wirklich zum Beispiel den
wander arbeiteten von den viele auf dem
Baustellen für die WM Stadien ums Leben
gekommen sind zugute kommen jetzt bleibt
natürlich noch die Frage es gab diesen
Riesenwirbel es gab die Einberufung des
Botschafters durch die cataris auch der
Emir er spricht Zitat von einer Kampagne
die sich da weiter durchreicht du hast
gesagt die Menschenrechtsbeauftragte
Luisa Amtsberg sie ist auch nicht
mitgereist was erlebst du denn für die
aktuelle Stimmung in diesen
zwischenmenschlichen Beziehungen in den
Debatten wie ist da die Atmosphäre bei
euch
also die Atmosphäre in Katar so viel wir
sind als ein paar Stunden hier ich
glaube so viel kann man schon sagen ist
schon angespannt auch unsere
Berichterstattung ist per se so ist das
in Katar eingeschränkt wir können jetzt
nicht einfach auf die Straße gehen und
Leute drehen oder einfach sozusagen man
nennt es die Box Pop machen da wird
streng darauf geachtet dass freie
fernsehteamster nicht einfach so durch
die Gegend laufen wir sind also
eingebunden den einen sagen wir mal in
eine Delegation aus Berlin die für zwei
Tage nach Katar gekommen ist das ist das
eine auf der anderen Seite sehen wir
schon
das selbstvertreter von
Nichtregierungsorganisationen die die
Interessen von Wanderarbeitern vertreten
betonen das neben vielen Problemen die
es nach wie vor gibt ein paar Schritte
gemacht wurden zum Beispiel als
Wanderarbeiter ihre Arbeitsstätten
wechseln können dass sie einklagen
können wenn ihnen der Lohn vorenthalten
wird wie schnell das geht und ob
Gerichte ihn dann auch recht geben das
ist noch mal eine völlig andere Frage
und ebenfalls eine andere Frage ist wie
das nach der WM dann anhält oder ob
bestimmter Reformen dann wieder
zurückgefahren werden viele offene
Fragen also in einer Situation wo
sozusagen auch die Anspannung insgesamt
in Katar stark wir sind vorher gerade an
einer Uhr vorbeigefahren die den
Countdown zum Beginn der WM-Zeit ich
glaube viele haben hier einfach auf den
Lampenfieber
viele offene Fragen sagst du eine noch
an Dich das geht mit Blick auf den
morgigen Tag wird es da Ergebnisse zu
präsentieren geben Aussagen weitere von
Phaser vielleicht auch konkrete oder
glaubst du es wird am Ende nur auf
dieses
hinauslaufen von ihr alles gut ich habe
mir das angeguckt
das glaube ich nicht also das Phaser
versuchen wird ist für deutsche Fans die
nach Katar Reisen eine Art
Sicherheitsgarantie zu bekommen von der
katarischen Regierung als der Emil von
Katar vor kurzem in Berlin war hat auf
die Frage nach dem Schutz zum Beispiel
von lgbq-gemeinschaften in Katar während
der WM gesagt jeder ist bei uns
willkommen und diesen Satz den wir sehr
gerne substanziell hinbekommen in der
Hinsicht das eben jemand der ein
deutscher Fan der in Katar mit einer
Regenbogenfahne durch die Straßen läuft
nicht festgenommen wird sondern das ist
eine Garantie gibt für freie Meinung
Äußerung und für die Sicherheit
deutscher Fans das ist das eine sie wird
auch wahrscheinlich den FIFA-Präsidenten
Infantino hier treffen wird ihn noch
einmal darauf ansprechen dass die FIFA
selbst eine Vorein richtet um Familien
von wm-arbeitern die bei den Bauarbeiten
verletzt oder sogar gestorben sind dass
die entschädigt werden da bewegt sich
die FIFA erst langsam in diese Richtung
das ist noch viel subst alles zu leisten
und am Ende hat gesagt wird sie selbst
entscheiden müssen ob für Sie das Glas
sozusagen von Katar halb voll oder halb
leer ist heißt ob sie wirklich selbst
dann zum Eröffnungsspiel der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft gegen Japan wieder
hierher kommen wird Thomas Reichert live
ausdoor für uns vor Ort er begleitet das
Treffen der bundesinnenministerin Nancy
fazer wir werden gespannt sein und auch
auf morgen schauen ob es dann
tatsächlich ihr gelingen wird diese
konkreten Punkte die du angesprochen
hast Thomas tatsächlich auch ja dass sie
dann so umgesetzt werden vielen Dank für
deine Eindrücke hier bei ZDF heute live
gleich bei uns in der Sendung die
Diskussion zwischen dem Ex FIFA man
Alexander Koch und zwischen dem human
right Direktor Wenzel Michalski vorher
wollen wir euch aber noch mal mitnehmen
in das Land Katar wir wollen euch zeigen
welche Lebens- und auch
Arbeitsbedingungen die Menschen dort
vorfinden und wir wollen auch noch mal
in Erinnerung rufen wie viele Menschen
den Bau der WM Stadien mit ihrem Leben
bezahlen mussten Moritz Neuss
mit weniger als 12.000 Quadratkilometern
ist die Halbinsel Katar das kleinste
Land am Persischen Golf und 2,6
Millionen Menschen leben hier doch nur
etwa 11% von ihnen sind katari der Rest
ArbeitsmigrantInnen und Migranten vor
allem aus armen asiatischen Ländern
damit sind etwa 90% der Menschen einzig
und allein zum Arbeiten im Land für
viele von ihnen ist das die einzige
Möglichkeit nicht nur ihr eigenes
Überleben zu sichern sondern auch das
ihrer Familien immer wieder kommen
Bilder von den Lebens- und
Arbeitsbedingungen der Migranten in
Katar ans Licht und hygienische Baracken
schuften bei 45 Grad in der Sonne allein
zwischen 2010 und 2019 sollen laut
Amnesty International 15.021 nicht
catari alle Altersgruppen in dem Land
gestorben sein die Ursachen für die
Todesfälle würden meist nicht angemessen
untersucht ihre Familien im Unklaren
gelassen laut dem britischen Guardian
sollen 30 Todesfälle direkt auf den Bau
der die Renovierung der acht WM-Stadien
zurückzuführen sein es sei jedoch
wahrscheinlich dass ein Großteil der
Todesfälle in Verbindung mit dem
Bauprojekten für die WM steht gegen die
systematische Ausbeutung aufzubegehren
scheint aus Sicht der Arbeitsmigranten
aussichtslos zu groß ist die Angst vor
Inhaftierung oder Jobverlust zudem
ziehen Arbeitgeber oft die Pässe ein ein
System das die Arbeiter quasi zu
Leibeigenen macht
infonat41 von uns die FIFA hat vor sechs
Tagen eine offizielle Meldung
rausgegeben in der sie von lediglich
drei Todesopfern spricht die in
Verbindung mit dem Bau der WM Stadien
stehen sollen so rüber in unsere
Diskussion wenn sie mich als die
Direktor von human right Swatch wir
haben die Zahlen gehört und auch diese
offizielle Meldung dem sollen wir denn
da jetzt glauben
also zu den Zahlen können wir von human
right Swatch nicht sagen wir haben sie
nicht untersucht tatsache aber ist dass
ungefähr 70 Prozent aller Todesfälle und
der Arbeitsmigranten unaufgeklärt sind
und das ist ein Teil unserer Forderung
wir fordern von der Regierung Qatar
diese Todesfälle wirklich aufzuklären es
steht jetzt da lediglich tot durch
Herzversagen oder sowas ähnliches und
das ist schon erstaunlich wenn ein
samura 25-jähriger Mann plötzlich eines
Morgens nicht mehr aufwacht aber den Tag
vorher noch ganz normal gearbeitet hat
und dann steht dann tot durch
Herzversagen muss man sich fragen warum
wie viel Grad waren es denn an dem Tag
davor der an dem man geschuftet hat wie
viel Stunden musste der Mann ohne Wasser
ohne Ruhepause schuften das sind alles
so die Fragen die jetzt erst aufzuklären
sind und dann weiß man auch wie viel
Menschen wirklich gestorben sind Herr
Koch jetzt haben wir die unabhängigen
Quellen die von mehreren tausend
Todesopfern sprechen sie waren
stellvertretender Kommunikationschef der
FIFA wissen also auch ja die
Kommunikationsprozesse der FIFA selbst
wie erklären Sie sich diese Diskrepanz
der Veröffentlichung der FIFA dass es
nur drei Todesopfer gegeben haben soll
also das ist zuerst mal nicht unbedingt
ein Widerspruch weil glaube ich niemand
gesagt hat dass 15.000 Leute auf einer
WM Baustelle gestorben sind die Zahl wie
die auch damals zustande gekommen ist
schon 2010 war ja dass man gesagt hat im
Jahr sterben im Schnitt ich sag jetzt
mal 600
Gastarbeiter das hat man dann auf zehn
Jahre hochgerechnet und auch noch
einkalkuliert das ist mehr Gastarbeiter
werden und so ist man auf diese Zahl
gekommen die Zahl 15.000 wird
wahrscheinlich stimmen also es gibt
jedenfalls keinen Grund die in Frage zu
stellen das 15.000 Gastarbeiter in
diesen letzten was waren es neun Jahren
gestorben sind die Frage ist ja wie viel
sind davon auf wm-baustellen gestorben
nicht dass wir da jetzt irgendwie ein
qualitativen Unterschied machen wollen
aber auf den wm-baustellen haben
insgesamt in den neuen Jahren 80.000 der
2,2 Millionen Gastarbeiter gearbeitet
und da sehen sie natürlich schon dass es
ein Verschwinden kleiner Teil ist und
auf diesem WM Baustellen aber die
Statistiken der FIFA sind drei direkt
durch ein Arbeitsunfall gestorben und
ich glaube das 36 oder 37 von den
Arbeitern die auf einer wellenbaustelle
gearbeitet haben sind gestorben und da
gebe ich ja nicht als gerecht es ist
natürlich ein Hunding dass diese
Todesursachen nicht aufgeklärt werden
denn warum sollten junge Menschen junge
Männer eines Tages auf einmal am
Herzinfarkt oder sowas sterben wird da
sollte ich viel klarer Aufklärung geben
Sie auch bei der bei der Zahl der drei
es gibt aber auch Recherchen der
britischen Tageszeitung ein the Guardian
eine unabhängige Quelle die auch sagt
dass über 6.500 migrierte Arbeiter
aufgrund der Arbeitsbedingungen an den
WM Stadien gestorben sind also noch mal
die Frage nicht das ist eben nicht ganz
richtig sondern die haben diese Zahl
6.500 damals aufgestellt und haben sie
projiziert in die Zukunft wir müssen
wissen als die WM geben wurde am 2
dezember 2010 gab es 1,1 Millionen
Gastarbeiter
das hat mit der WM erstmal gar nichts zu
tun 1,1 Millionen Gastarbeiter haben am
2 dezember in 2010 in Katar gearbeitet
zwei Jahre danach gab es die ersten
Veröffentlichungen dass jetzt 500 oder
600 Menschen auf der Einbaustellen
gestorben sein es gab damals noch keine
einzige wm-baustelle die wurde dann erst
eröffnet also von daher müsste man mit
diesen Zahlen schon ein bisschen
sorgfältiger sein jeder tot ist einer zu
viel das ist überhaupt keine Frage aber
die Frage ist was sind tote auf
wm-baustellen was sind nicht und jetzt
ist natürlich die Frage was ist eine
wm-baustelle ist das Hotel was gebaut
wird eine wm-baustelle oder nicht ist
der Flughafen der ausgebaut wird eine
wellenbaustelle oder nicht und jetzt die
Definition ist eben die wm-baustellen
sind die Baustellen wie von diesem
Organisation auch kontrolliert werden
sind mal alle stadienbauten und alles
was ausschließlich und direkt mit der WM
in zusammenhängt und da haben ja in in
den letzten Jahren insgesamt nur 80.000
Menschen gearbeitet von 2,2 Millionen
Gastarbeitern
das kann man nicht so sagen also zur WM
als wm-baustelle bezeichnen wir die
gesamte Infrastruktur die für die WM
erforderlich ist das heißt also
inklusive Hotels inklusive
Zufahrtsstraßen Restaurants und so
weiter und so fort und
das hat das auch damit etwas zu tun dass
gerade Katar ein Plan hat nämlich Tatar
2030 und Qatar 2022 die
Weltmeisterschaft sollte der Katalysator
für die Modernisierung dieses Landes
werden auf dass es hinzielt für das Jahr
2030 die sprechen allerdings über eine
ökonomische Modernisierung eine
technologische und architektonische
Modernisierung nicht Modernisierung im
Sinne der Menschenrechte und als die
FIFA damals die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft Katar
vergeben hat war schon klar welche
Zustände dort auf Baustellen insgesamt
in Qatar herrschen deswegen hätte Qatar
diesen Zuschlag niemals bekommen können
wir haben zwei Jahre vor der Vergabe
schon über die eklatante Situation für
Arbeitsmigranten in Qatar berichtet das
hat sich dann zum Teil auf wenigen
direkten wm-baustellen also die direkten
WM-Stadien die immer vorzeigebaustellen
waren wo eben so Leute wie sieht man
Gabriel und andere hingeführt worden
sind die dann gesagt haben euer sind ja
ganz ordentlich aus ja da war es auch
ganz ordentlich aber wir reden ja auch
von den vielen vielen vielen
Hunderttausenden Arbeitern
die eben nicht in den Genuss gekommen
sind direkt am Stadion zu arbeiten
ja ich stimme in jedem Wort zu und daher
kommt auch die Differenz wahrscheinlich
nicht in den Zahlen was ist eine
wellenbaustelle was nicht und die
Definition wm-baustelle die die FIFA das
Organisationskomitee benutzen sind halt
nur die Stadien und das was das
Organisationskomitee kontrolliert und
dort sind laut Gewerkschaften die
Arbeitsbedingungen hervorragend was aber
nicht für die letzte den Rest der 2,1
Millionen gastarbeitergeld das ist
richtig also ich halte hier aber an der
Stelle noch mal fest dass es Berichte
von unabhängigen Quellen gibt die von
mehreren tausend Todesfällen sprechen
die sind unabhängig die sind
recherchiert und eben die offizielle
Meldung der FIFA die dabei bleibt und
auch Herr Koch bleibt bei dieser Meinung
jetzt sind wir schon bei dem Aspekt der
Situation der Arbeiter der Gastarbeiter
den menschenfachen wir haben Bilder
gesehen in Dokumentation zum Beispiel im
ZDF ja auch oder auch von Sport inside
Kollegen der ARD die das rausgegeben
haben vielleicht können wir die Bilder
auch ganz kurz einmal einblenden lieber
Regie dass wir das einmal hier noch mal
sehen können unter schlechten
Bedingungen Menschen dort die Stadien
bauen mussten bauen müssen hier haben
wir das
dort arbeiten sie aber es gibt natürlich
auch Bilder davon wie sie in
Unterkünften zusammengefährcht tausen
müssen wie sie da unter
menschenverachtenden Bedingungen einfach
leben müssen das sehen wir jetzt gerade
Herr Koch
2015 haben sie in einer TV-Sendung bei
Günther Jauch gesagt dass Zitat die
Vergabe der WM an Katar ist gut für die
Arbeiter zwei Fragen an sie wie kommen
Sie zu dieser Einschätzung bei diesen
Bildern und auch bei diesen Fällen
worüber besprechen und hat sich ihre
Position dazu geändert seitdem sie nicht
mehr Teil der FIFA sind
also zum ersten Teil der Frage und
vielleicht auch noch mal zu den Zahlen
die Sie gerade erwähnt haben ich selbst
kann ja diese Arbeitsbedingungen nicht
beurteilen darum beziehe ich für mich
auch nicht auf irgendwelche FIFA Quellen
sondern auch die Quelle der
Gewerkschaften die unter anderem Dietmar
Schäfers der dort regelmäßig ist und der
im Namen dieser Gewerkschaft die
Arbeitsbedingungen auf den wm-baustellen
untersucht hat und er hat vom
Bundesausschuss Sportausschuss von
Deutschen Bundestag noch mal gesagt und
mir gegenüber auch dass die Bedingungen
auf diesen arbeitsbaustellen besser sein
als in Deutschland oder der Schweiz sie
gehören zu den besten der Welt das ist
eine Äußerung der Gewerkschaft und das
bezieht sich wohlgemerkt nur auf diese
WM Baustellen
er hat mich ebenfalls darum gebeten
damals
2015 und Gottes Willen nimmt die WM
nicht von Katar Weg das wäre das
Schlimmste denn dann würde sich niemand
mehr für die Arbeiter in Partei
interessieren bis zur WM-Vergabe durften
Gewerkschaften nicht mal in das Land
gehen und mit der Regierung über
irgendetwas sprechen oder sich
irgendwelche Baustellen anschauen das
Land bei hermetisch abgeriegelt aufgrund
der WM-Vergabe und des Medieninteresses
und des Druckes von AIO und andern er
hat sich dann das Land geöffnet und hat
Gewerkschaften reingelassen und darum
ist das auch ein berechtigtes Interesse
aller dieser Menschenrechtsorganisation
am Gewerkschaften dieses dieses Momentum
zu nutzen für ihre Anliegen und sich in
dieser Zeit so lange die Aufmerksamkeit
dort ist für die Menschen einzusetzen
und die Arbeitsbedingungen zu verbessern
und die Arbeitsbedingungen sind laut
Gewerkschaft zumindest für diese
Menschen deutlich verbessert worden und
darum habe ich meine Meinung eigentlich
nicht geändert und die
Arbeitsbedingungen waren
schrecklich und sind es bis heute für
ein Großteil der Arbeiter aber durch die
WM-Vergabe hat sich die Situation wenn
dann verbessert aber sicherlich nicht
schlecht
Anschlussfrage Herr Koch kommt von
unserem User berechtigter Punkt von mobi
er fragt das Gute tiert man jetzt
wirklich darüber das geht in ihre
Richtung wie die WM zu legitimieren ist
aufgrund der Frage ob nun mehr
Zwangsarbeiter wegen der WM oder wegen
anderer Projekte gestorben sind sein
Zitat es geht um Menschenleben
ja das ist eine absolut berechtigte
Frage also wenn ich das vielleicht auch
noch mal vorher aufnehmen im Grunde
genommen müsste man ja diskutieren
inwiefern müssten Bedingungen in einem
Land bereits erfüllt sein damit es sich
überhaupt in meine bewerben bewerben
kann oder der Mitte ist den Zuschlag für
eine werden bekommt und da haben wir
auch oftmals darüber nachgedacht wie man
das machen könnte das werden sie aber
sehen ist sehr schwierig dort eine Linie
zu ziehen von der man sagen kann so
dieses Land erfülltes dieses Land
erfülltes noch nicht bei Katar würde man
sicherlich zurecht sagen die
Arbeitsbedingungen sind so erbärmlich
dass sie in diesem Aspekt sich nicht
qualifizieren eine WM zu organisieren
das würde ihnen auch bestätigen aber ich
glaube er Gabriel hat ja jetzt auch
gefragt wie ist es mit Mexiko wie ist es
in Brasilien wie was in Südafrika also
es gibt ja in allen Ländern immer viele
Missstände und wer zieht dort die Linie
und sagt ab dieser ab diesem Level seid
ihr berechtigten WM zu organisieren und
diese sicherlich mit dem Sportverband
wie die FIFA führen treffen also das
wäre die große Schwierigkeit bei so
einer durchaus berechtigten
Anspruchshaltung aber die Umsetzung ist
sehr schwierig Herr Michalski was ist
ihre Position dazu
also meine Position unserer Position ist
es dass ein Land das solche Bedingungen
hat wo Menschenrechte somit Füßen
getreten werden nicht damit belohnt
werden darf mit einer Weltmeisterschaft
dass dieses Land dann auch noch zu einer
propaganda-show für sich missbraucht und
das ist der Fall in Katar klar ja es gab
Verbesserungen aber sie sind nicht
deswegen gekommen weil die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft dort ist
sondern sie sind deswegen geschehen weil
mutige kluge Journalisten recherchiert
haben und gute Beiträge geschrieben
haben gute Filme gemacht haben das
hatten auch in letzter Zeit gesehen weil
ZDF bei ARD bei RTL und so weiter
und es ist auch deswegen gewesen weil
wir recherchiert haben wir Berichte
verfasst haben und Amnesty und versquare
und andere und dadurch einen großen
internationalen Druck auch auf die FIFA
ausgeübt haben dass die FIFA jetzt immer
noch so resistent ist immer behauptet es
sei nur drei Tote auf diesem Baustellen
gewesen und sich nicht weiter zu äußern
noch nicht mal zu einer doch sehr
moderaten Forderung nämlich einen
Zahlungsform einzurichten für die
Familien der Arbeiter die gestorben sind
auf dem Baustellen oder die verletzt
worden sind und deswegen nicht mehr
arbeiten können die kommen aus ganz
armen Verhältnissen die Arbeiter aus
Bangladesch aus Nepal wir müssen mit
ihren paar Kröten die sie da verdienen
300 Euro müssen die ganze Familien
Großfamilien mit annähern und jetzt
können diese Kinder die Kinder diese
Arbeiter nicht mehr in die Schule weil
der brotverdiener gestorben ist
ich war selber in solchen
Wohnsiedlungen in Katar und habe gesehen
wie die Arbeiter dort hausen müssen das
ist wirklich erbärmlich und wirklich
schrecklich aber ich muss auch sagen die
kommen selber aus ganz furchtbaren
Gegenden das ist noch nicht mal das
allerschlimmste obwohl es schlimm ist
das schlimmste ist wenn diese Menschen
nicht bezahlt werden und wir mussten
noch im März ein Bericht veröffentlichen
über eine Firma die direkt in Katar in
in wm-projekte verwickelt ist oder
involviert ist eine Baufirma die über
fünf Monate lang ihre Arbeiter nicht
bezahlt hat also ein Arbeiter der nur
300 Euro im Monat verdient wenn
überhaupt und davon den größten Teil
nach Hause schicken muss ist das ein
Desaster für jeden von uns wäre es ein
zu saß da
ganz kurz was zu sagen
ja
ich stimme ihn ja zu die FIFA hat ja
auch die werden nicht nach Katar
vergeben mit der Absicht die
Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern das war
wahrscheinlich nicht mal Thema bei
denjenigen die dort abgestimmt haben
aber was sie gerade gesagt haben die
Bedingungen haben sich nicht deshalb
verbessert weil die WM Deutschland
gefunden hat jawohl nur deshalb haben
sie ja dort arbeiten können und nur
deshalb haben sie Medien medialen Druck
ausgeübt das ist kein Verdienst der FIFA
aber das ist ein
Resultat der Tatsache dass die WM dort
stattfindet denn sie haben die gleichen
Erfolge ja nicht in Bangladesch Nepal
und
Pakistan erreicht in den letzten Jahren
wo wie sie sagen die Arbeitsbedingungen
noch viel schlechter sind sondern sie
nutzen zu Recht und das ist auch gut so
die mediale Plattform der WM um endlich
die Anliegen in die Öffentlichkeit zu
bringen und deshalb hat sich etwas
verändert ohne die WM hätten wir noch
genau die gleichen Arbeitsbedingungen
Qatar wir am 2 dezember 2010 sie werden
ja nicht mal reingekommen in das Land
sie hätten gar keinen Zugang gehabt
doch wir waren ja schon vorher drin und
haben genau solche Verhältnisse wie wir
sie jetzt sehen schon vor 12 14 Jahren
darüber berichtet und es hat sich aber
nichts verändert das ist es ja die
Gewerkschaften kein Zugang und sie sehen
Sie alle NGOs sagen ja zurecht jetzt
haben wir endlich die Chance dass man
uns mal zuhört und dass man unsere
Anliegen ernst nimmt was war das gleiche
in Brasilien mit dem Komitee popular da
die haben auch gesagt 15 Jahre lang ist
keiner zu uns gekommen und jetzt haben
wir endlich die Plattform der WM und
konnten die ganzen Missstände in
Brasilien mal an die Öffentlichkeit
bringen seit der WM 2014 redet kein
Mensch mehr darüber wie das Sozialsystem
ist und wie ungerecht das System in
Brasilien ist und das das muss man
einfach sein dass nicht daran dass eine
Weltmeisterschaft der Olympische Spiele
oder gegen jede große Veranstaltung eine
mediale Plattform bieten und die wird zu
Recht genutzt von NGOs
gut aber wenn sie sagen redet kein
Mensch mehr darüber dann meinen sie
natürlich wahrscheinlich wir Menschen in
Deutschland die sonst ja also
sie haben nicht mehr seine Audios genau
natürlich aber es geht ja nicht nur
darum natürlich ist ein Land das so eine
so große mega Sportveranstaltung bekommt
ob das jetzt Olympische Spiele sind oder
ob das die WM ist
dann natürlich ein Mittelpunkt die
Menschenrechtssituation oder überhaupt
die Zustände in dem Land die stehen dann
im Mittelpunkt des medialen Interesses
weil der Scheinwerfer nicht drauf fällt
das ist ganz klar
aber umso absurder ist es doch dass ich
Qatar jetzt darüber beschwert dass Nancy
Faeser die Menschenrechtssituation in
Katar
kritisiert hat das lässt eigentlich
befürchten dass die Verbesserung die
jetzt da sind vor allem aber auf dem
Papier da sind und noch nicht umgesetzt
worden sind außer bei einigen Ausnahmen
dass die nicht nachhaltig sind das heißt
dass wenn der Scheinwerfer wegrückt der
WM Scheinwerfer wegdrückt und niemand
mehr so richtig hinschaut dass dann die
Situation in Katar wieder so sein wird
auch da wo sie sich vielleicht
verbessert hat wie vorher deswegen
fordern wir ja von der FIFA vor allem
dass sie sich in Katar für nachhaltige
Verbesserung einsetzt damit man dann
sagen kann aha der Sport der hat doch
etwas Gutes bewirkt bisher hat es das
noch nie getan
Qatar wäre ein Beispiel gewesen man
hatte 12 Jahre lang Zeit daran zu
arbeiten und die FIFA hat bis heute
Schweigen gehalten sie hat sich in
Schweigen gehüllt wenn es um die
Menschenrechte ging
also
ganz kurz dazu was man wie man die
nachhaltig garantieren kann also das ist
dass die Gefahr besteht dass das im
Rückschritt danach wieder gibt das teile
ich absolut das haben wir auch andere
Länder China oder so schon bewiesen dass
das nicht unbedingt nachhaltig sein muss
und ich glaube die Kritik jetzt an den
Kataris das ist ein bisschen eine
Sensibilität die sind halt so dermaßen
stark kritisiert worden dass sie es
langsam leid sind und sie sagen kommen
und wir haben doch schon mehr gemacht
als alle anderen ungeliegenden Staaten
jetzt hört auf uns ständig zu
kritisieren und ich glaube das ist auch
das Sigmar Gabriel sagen würde dass wenn
die Kritik zu laut wird und vor allen
Dingen die Erfolge nicht auch mal
erwähnt werden dass es dann
kontraproduktiv werden könnte ich gehe
ganz kurz an der Stelle rein beim Thema
Arbeiterrechte trotzdem müssen wir
festhalten dass Herr Koch auch das
beim Bau der Stadien einfach die
Menschen gestorben sind wegen der wegen
des Baus der WM Stadion und das unter
menschenverachtenden Bedingungen das zum
Thema Situation der Arbeiter und der
Situation der Arbeiter der die Stadien
gebaut haben das ist aber nur ein Punkt
es ist der größte ist einer der
wichtigsten ein zweiter Punkt sind aber
auch die Menschenrechte auf
Homosexualität steht in Katar bis zu
fünf Jahre Gefängnis queere Menschen
werden in dem Land verfolgt also auch da
die Frage an Sie was kann da die WM
verändern
an uns beide die Frage oder fangen Sie
gerne an
schwierig das ist sehr schwierig also
dass die Gesetze verändert und so ich
glaube darauf aufmerksam zu machen dass
die Welt Öffentlichkeit damit nicht
einverstanden ist ist zufällig das eine
aber rein juristisch hat
in Fifa da keine Möglichkeit jetzt
staatlichen Gesetze zu verhindern sie
hat schon relativ viel Einfluss auf die
staatenweise zum Beispiel die mediale
Berichterstattung glauben muss jeder der
ein Ticket hat muss einreisen dürfen
also auch wenn die WM in Saudi Arabien
stattfinden würde müssten Israelis
einreisen dürfen das sind gewisse Sachen
die zumindest für die Zeit der WM
gegeben sind aber
nachhaltig ein Gesetz zu ändern
so direkt kann sie das nicht
hey Michalski
ja also
das zeigt ja eigentlich wieder dieses
Beispiel warum die WM dort nicht hätte
stattfinden dürfen denn schon damals als
die WM-Vergabe an Katar geschehen ist
hat ja die FIFA einen Werte gewusst
gehabt und sie hat und das Werte Gerüst
das umfasste
Gleichberechtigung auch gleiche Liebe
dass das nicht unterdrückt werden darf
dass Frauen gleiche Rechte haben dass es
eine freie Medienberichterstattung gibt
all das ist in Katar nicht gegeben wir
haben ja eben gerade ihren Kollegen
gehört der erzählt hat er kann da gar
nicht so richtig im Land rumfahren oder
in der Stadt rumfahren um sich die Dinge
anzusehen die haben ja schon Kataris
haben wir schon den Medien schaffenden
gesagt ihr dürft die und die und die
Orte besuchen aber sonst überhaupt
nichts das heißt
die Werte die die FIFA nach außen
vertritt hat sie selber verraten aber es
ist eigentlich müßig darüber jetzt zu
reden das ist alles schon länger her die
WM wird jetzt auch stattfinden aber
es sollte doch wenigstens eine Lehre
daraus gezogen werden jetzt hat die FIFA
sich auch eine menschenrechtsagenda
gegeben und an die musste sich halten in
Zukunft und das heißt nicht dass es
irgendwie aus dem Westen ein Europäer
sagt hört mal zu ihr da in Katar ihr
müsst das so und so machen mit dem
erhobenen Zeigefinger sondern es geht
hier um die Menschenrechte und die
Menschenrechte sind global ein Land hat
dann keine Souveränität über die
Menschen wenn es die Menschenrechte mit
Füßen tritt Menschenrechtsverletzungen
sind keine innere Angelegenheit und das
gilt auch für Katar da kann sich die
Regierung von Katar nicht arrogant
hinstellen und sagen ich verbitte mir
jede Kritik nur weil ich einen schwulen
foltere oder weil ich die freie
Berichterstattung nicht gewährleiste all
das ist ja passiert gerade
Ende letzten Jahres wurde ein
norwegisches Fernsehteam festgenommen
und festgehalten wir haben im September
noch Fälle gehabt von Leuten aus der
LGBT Momente die gefoltert worden sind
die ins Gefängnis geschmissen worden
sind deren Daten erfasst worden sind die
total abgehört worden sind werden in
teamsphäre verletzt worden sind und das
findet alles jetzt statt Klasse
geben für mich als geht das ein
wichtiger Punkt
sie sprechen es an sie beschreiben das
und sie nennen das Wort Arroganz
das Wort Arroganz ist in den vergangenen
Tagen auch von Sigmar Gabriel gefallen
wir können mal gemeinsam auf seine
Aussagen schauen bei Twitter die Deutsch
bezieht das nämlich auf die deutsche
Arroganz das ist ein Zitat hier können
wir uns das Anschauen bei Twitter gerne
einmal einblenden er sagt die deutsche
Arroganz gegenüber Katar ist zum KO
Punkt Punkt Punkt wie vergesslich sind
wir eigentlich Homosexualität war bis
1994 in Deutschland strafbar meine
Mutter braucht sie noch die Erlaubnis
des Ehemanns und zu arbeiten
Gastarbeiter haben wir Zitat beschissen
behandelt und miserabel untergebracht
und auch wir haben Jahrzehnte gebraucht
um ein liberales Land zu werden Herr
Michalski sie beschreiben gerade Fälle
von Verfolgung von Menschenrechten wir
haben sie dieses Zitat von Sigmar
Gabriel dann aufgenommen als sie das
gewesen sind erstmal habe ich mir
gewünscht oder für ihn gewünscht dass er
mit dem kotzen fertig ist und die sind
jetzt besser geht und zweitens muss ich
sagen das eigentlich ist einer sehr
arrogante Haltung von einem der sich als
Lobby für dieses Land da irgendwie
hergibt ich weiß auch nicht warum er das
tut aber
erstens weiß ich nicht dass 1994 bei uns
noch Homosexuelle gefoltert worden sind
zweitens ist das eine Relativierung denn
wie ich eben gesagt habe die
Menschenrechte gelten für alle Menschen
immer und überall und auch wenn sie
jetzt in Deutschland zum Beispiel
irgendwann vor einigen Jahrzehnten nicht
gegolten haben dann kann das kein Grund
sein warum ich jetzt heute dann Auge zu
drücken muss
wie gesagt Menschenrechte ist keine
restliche Erfindung sondern es ist eine
eine Vereinbarung der Vereinten Nation
unterschrieben von allen Mitgliedstaaten
der vereinbaren dass der Vereinten
Nationen und dazu gehört auch Katar auch
der grünen Politiker ich zitierte das
jetzt mal Volker Beck hat geantwortet an
Gabriel Zitat sie setzen allen Ernstes
die Situation von Homosexuellen in
Deutschland 1994 mit der von Katar 2022
gleich sie haben doch Zitat einen Sprung
in der Schüssel mit ihrer
despotenversteherei Herr Koch wie haben
sie die Aussagen von Herrn Gabriel
wahrgenommen
Vergleiche sind ungeübt also ich würde
nie jetzt ein Land wie Deutschland mit
Katar vergleichen oder eine Gesetzgebung
vergleichen also ich habe jetzt das auch
nicht so wörtlich genommen sondern mehr
versucht zu verstehen was er nicht damit
sagen wollte und er wollte sagen dass
der Gesetze oder ein Land sich nicht von
heute auf morgen eine kultursitzung von
heute auf morgen verändert sondern dass
das Zeit braucht und dass man wenn man
zu viel Druck ausübt dass das dann
produziert ist so habe ich das
eigentlich gesehen jetzt wortwörtlich zu
nehmen ob die Homosexuellen Verfolgung
bis 1994 in Deutschland
glauben sie an diese Zeit glauben Sie an
dieser Entwicklung ich meine der Blick
in die Vergangenheit zeigt ja hat auch
er mich als die beschrieben dass ich das
auch nach Sportveranstaltungen in
autokratischen Ländern nicht gedreht hat
glauben sie an diese Zeit Veränderung
ich kann es nur hoffen ich könnte jetzt
keine keine Einschätzung wirklich geben
ich habe das Gefühl die Welt hat jetzt
wirklich 12 Jahre lang da drauf geschaut
auch die die Menschen
erfahren ja ein anderes Bewusstsein in
dem Land und auch wie Arbeiter die jetzt
gesehen haben das ist anders geht aber
ich würde jetzt auch nichts Wetten also
da kann ich keine
Prognose machen ob sich das wirklich
nicht wieder zurück entwickelt aber
vielleicht darf ich mal ganz kurz
sagen Gabriel jetzt auch aus der
Wirtschaft kommen und so das
Interessante ist ja und da sehe ich so
ein bisschen die Scheinheiligkeit in die
wir Diskussion das Interessante ist es
ja dass es dann nicht eine FIFA gibt und
dann gibt es die anderen können der
Druck auch warum die werden überhaupt
nach Katar vergeben wurde der kam ja aus
der Wirtschaft ja diese diese 14
Personen die für paar Tage stimmt haben
die haben ja nicht dafür gestimmt weil
es für die FIFA gut ist für die FIFA ist
die Wärme mit Katana Kat Produkte
gewesen es war das Worst Case darum hat
ja auch die Administration versucht die
WM-Vergabe nach Katar möglichst
unattraktiv zu machen aber wenn die
Wirtschaft und zwar auch in Deutschland
von Präsidenten Wulff der mit dem
Blatter gesprochen hat und gesagt hat es
wäre schön wenn die WM nach Katar gehen
würde oder er sagte sie in Frankreich
ist Michelle Platini gesagt hat und wer
sind denn die Arbeitgeber in Katar wer
ist denn mit diesen Arbeiten mit den
Gastarbeitern in rechtlichen
Beziehung das ist ja nicht die hinter
sondern es sind Unternehmen aus
Deutschland wie Siemens Hochtief
Wilfinger Berger und so weiter und so
fort und wenn also ein wirtschaftliches
Interesse daran besteht in Katar
möglichst viele Aufträge zu bekommen und
dieser Druck dann auf die Sportwelt
übertragen wird also dann finde ich
sollte man ernsthaft überlegen mit
welcher ob da nicht mit zweierlei Maß
gemessen wird auf der einen Seite wenn
man das große Geld machen auf der
anderen Seite soll dann aber der Sport
dafür sorgen dass die
manchmal Situationen verbessert wird das
finde ich es scheinheilig
das ist scheinheilig und ich muss sagen
ich habe mich auch sehr gewundert als
ich den Wirtschaftsminister habe in
Katar gesehen hat und er ein sehr tiefen
Diener gemacht hat vor dem Emir oder
auch jetzt nennt sie Feser die dahin
fährt und sagt nachdem sie ganz kurze
Zeit nur da ist ich habe einen positiven
Eindruck und dann die Gesprächspunkte
der katarischen Regierung wiedergibt was
übrigens habe ich auch gemacht hat und
Scholz nämlich
ja es muss noch einiges getan werden es
hat ja sich aber schon viel verbessert
und dieses aber dann wegfallen lassen
und dieses aber heißt aber das was ich
verbessert hat steht vor allem auf ein
paar auf dem Papier und ist noch nicht
implementiert worden ja das ist ja der
entscheidende Punkt hat sich überhaupt
was verbessert und wird ist das auch auf
lange Sicht der Michalski
also punktuell für einige privilegierte
Arbeiter auf den direkten wm-baustellen
hat sich etwas verbessert und es gibt
auch
Wiedergutmachungszahlungen für einige
Familien deren Angehörige auf dem
Baustellen gestorben sind das gilt aber
nur ab einem gewissen seit zwei Jahren
ist das erste und alle die vielen vielen
tausenden die vorher gestorben sind die
gehen leer aus es gehen auch diejenigen
leer aus die Familien die hoch
verschuldet sind weil
arbeitsvermittlungsgebühren angefallen
sind in vielen in der Höhe von von 1500
Dollar zum Beispiel die diese Menschen
nie zurück bezahlen können
also die Verbesserung die es gibt
greifen viel zu kurz und das wird halt
nicht angesprochen
aber System ist für alle Arbeiter
abgeschafft worden ob es für alle schon
umgesetzt wurde ist eine andere Frage
aber es ist zumindest auf dem Papier für
alle abgeschafft worden ja auf dem
Papier ist viel passiert aber auf dem
Papier Agenda Setting ist einfach was
aufs Papier zu schreiben ist einfach das
umzusetzen und das zum Leben zu erwecken
das ist schwierig und in Katar ja da
sieht man irgendwie auch nicht so
wichtig
den Willen dahinter per tars eins der
reichsten Länder der Welt wieso
erlauben sie sich eigentlich die
Arbeiter so schrecklich auszubeuten
ja ich glaube das kann sie für alle
arabischen Staaten
sagen diese Frage stellen die sind ja
alle erreicht die Länder dort
und von daher ist es umso stoßender
eigentlich zu sehen dass jeder katari
ist ja Millionär kriegt er bei der
Hochzeit schon mal eine Millionen Dollar
und und ein Stück Land geschenkt also
die sind sowieso alles Millionäre und
dann ist es natürlich stoßend zu sehen
dass dann ein Arbeiter damit ein paar
hundert Dollar im Monat abgespeist wird
die sind bei diesem Thema Reichtum aber
kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt diesem
Reichtum ist nämlich der FIFA ist die
FIFA verfallen FIFA Mitglieder der
Direktor der us-steuerfahndung er
spricht mit Blick auf die WM in Katar
von einer Weltmeisterschaft der
Korruption die US-Staatsanwaltschaft sie
hat auch schon bestätigt es gibt
mindestens vier Delegierte ehemalige
Wahlmänner die mit direkten Zahlungen
bestochen worden sind mit Blick auf die
Vergabe der WM in Katar Herr Koch sie
waren als die Vergabe stattfand im Jahr
2010 stellvertretender
Kommunikationschef der FIFA sie waren
Teil des Ganzen haben sie diese
Bestechungen diese Korruption damals
auch mitbekommen und gesehen
wenn natürlich nicht also wenn die FIFA
das mitbekommen würde dann würde er
irgendwas falsch laufen es werden ja
Personen bestochen und darüber wird
sicherlich nicht die FIFA Administration
informiert dass irgendjemand aus
Südamerika oder wo auch immer oder ist
Europa dass der jetzt irgendwelche
Vorteile bekommen sollte von den kataren
also davon haben wir gar nichts
mitbekommen aber
sie haben Recht
dieses System ist sehr
korruptionsanfällig und darum haben wir
damals auch an einem alternativen System
gearbeitet und ich bin bis heute der
Meinung dass das System dringend
reformiert werden musste und weil ist
wie genau würden sich das wünschen und
vorstellen also wir haben damals eine
Studienauftrag gegeben welches System am
wenigsten für Produktion anfällig ist
und das ist das sogenannte gewichtete
Losverfahren da werden Kriterien
festgesetzt allein das ist schon mal
sehr wichtig dass diese Kriterien dann
auch eine gewissen Bedeutung haben und
nicht einfach nur auf dem Papier stehen
wenn Kriterien festgesetzt sagen wir mal
Sicherheit
Infrastruktur Entfernung CO2
Menschenrechte alles mögliche und dann
werden sie jeden Kriterium werden die
bewertet und es gibt zum Beispiel
maximal zehn Punkte und man muss in
jedem einzelnen Kriterium vier Punkte
als Minimum haben ja so und dann
entscheiden aber nicht Personen denn das
ist das große Problem Personen sollten
das nicht entscheiden am Schluss
entscheidet das Los aber das Land mit
der besten bewertung für seine Bewerbung
hat viel mehr größere Chancen die werden
zu bekommen als ein Land was eine
schlechte bildbewerbung abgegeben hat
also nochmal wenn wir bei 10 Kriterien
sind und mit maximal 10 Punkten dann hat
die beste Bewerbung 100 Punkte und die
schlechteste wenn man sagt unter 4
kriegt man raus hat in jedem nur vier
hat nur 40 und dann würde man in eine
große in einen großen Topf 40 Kugeln von
dem einen Bewerber und 100 Kugeln von
online machen aber dann muss das Los
entscheiden denn das habe ich auch in
den vielen Jahren festgestellt die
Bewerbung als solche spielt bei der
WM-Vergabe überhaupt keine Rolle also
die Personen machen ihre
Wahlentscheidung nicht davon abhängig
wie eine Bewerbung ist im Zweifel
schauen Sie sich die nicht einmal an und
dann spielen ganz andere Gründe dort
eine Rolle das sind persönliche Gründe
das sind politische Gründe und da habe
ich dieses Beispiel erlebt dass der
Vertreter von
argentinienpolio brandona damals auf
meine Frage haben wir die Bewerbung von
England fand gesagt hat der Herr kocht
ich kann ihn eins sagen solange ich lebe
werde ich dafür sorgen dass kein
einziges Mitglied der conmeyball das
sind die südamerikanischen Verbände
jemals für England stimmen wird und ich
hatte das am Anfang auch nicht sofort
verstanden dass mir klar wurde das lag
am Falklandkrieg und den interessiert
das gar nicht wenn England gegen
Nordkorea antreten würde dann wäre seine
Stimme bei Nordkorea so und da wurde mir
bewusst dass es keinen Sinn macht wenn
Personen über so etwas entscheiden weil
jeder seine eigene Vergangenheit hat und
wenn Israel sich bewirbt kriegen sie
keine einzige Stimme aus der arabischen
Welt wenn ein afrikanisches Land sich
bewirbt haben sie 53 stimmensicher weil
die anderen afrikanischen Länder für
dieses Land Stimmen werden und darum
muss die Entscheidung weg von Personen
die nicht immer nur zu Unrecht auch ein
persönliches Interesse haben also
persönlich ist für ihren Verband
und wenn ich das nach ihm sagen kann
jetzt hatte ich glaube auf der
DFB-Präsident ja gesagt die hätten oder
in Kantine und wir hätten einen Schritt
gemacht und das System sei ja reformiert
und jetzt würden die 200 11
Präsidenten der Fußballverbände
Mitgliedsverbände die Entscheidung
verändern das sei ja viel viel besser
bei Korruption dann viel weniger möglich
sein ich halte von diesem von dieser
Änderung überhaupt nicht weil von diesen
20011 Personen 140 überhaupt gar nicht
betroffen sind weil ihr Land gar nicht
an seine Weltmeisterschaft spielt
und wenn sie gewählter Präsident oder
Präsidentin des Fußballverbandes von
Liechtenstein oder Burkina Phase oder
PUK Island sind dann müssen Sie die
Interesse ihres Verbandes vertreten wenn
es dann um eine WM-Vergabe geht dann
stellen sie zurecht die Frage warum soll
ich für England Frankreich oder
Deutschland Stimmen naja aber wir müssen
ja trotzdem verkaufen bisher trotzdem
festhalten dass die Funktionäre das
haben wir auch ausgearbeitet im Fall
Katar bei der erstbesten Gelegenheit dem
Geld und den Hals gefallen sind und
damit noch nicht die Interessen
vertreten haben und deswegen werden
meine Anschlussfrage an Herrn Michalski
glauben Sie denn dass ich da so eine
Veränderung so ein System wie es Herr
Koch ja auch beschrieben hat dass das
überhaupt eine Kraft in diesem Verband
entwickeln kann kann sich das überhaupt
ändern
also ist wirklich nicht an mir die
Organisation FIFA irgendwie zu
beurteilen Herr Koch hat ja schon eben
geschildert was für ein problematische
Verein das ist
was für mich wichtig ist als
Menschenrechtler ist dass sich die FIFA
einen Menschenrechts Agenda gegeben hat
und dass sie sich daran halten muss wenn
das wenn wir sehen bei den nächsten Mal
wenn wieder die Entscheidung sind ob das
jetzt nur doof auf dem Papier rum steht
oder ob das tatsächlich eine
ernstzunehmende und ernst genommene
Aufgabe ist der FIFA um den Sport auch
zu retten denn immer mehr Fans wenden
sich ja ab die sagen mit mit Abscheu die
sagen so ein Verein will ich überhaupt
gar nicht mehr unterstützen das nimmt er
den Spaß Weg am Sport ist auch unfair
den Fußballern gegenüber die natürlich
auch wie jeder andere Mensch auch mehr
oder weniger ausgeprägte politische
Gewissen haben und moralische
Bedürfnisse haben und dann gedrungen
sind in solchen Ländern spielen zu
müssen da kann man ja auch nicht die
beste Leistung geben also das ist nicht
fairen Sportlern gegenüber den Fans
gegenüber
was aber darüber steht ist dass es eine
Verpflichtung gibt und zwar wieder eine
Verpflichtung der Vereinten Nationen
jeder Organisation oder jedes
Unternehmens
führt die Menschen aufzukommen für die
Angehörigen aufzukommen
deren
deren Arbeiter also für die für die
Familien der Arbeiter aufzukommen die
bei der Ausübung einer Tätigkeit
gestorben sind also eine Kompensation
das ist kein schönes Wort aber immerhin
dass sie da nicht in eine materielle Not
stürzen und das ist die Pflicht der FIFA
und das musste jetzt tun ob sie hier
später Menschenrechte tatsächlich gibt
oder nicht wenn sie das nicht tut dann
ist es eine Pflichtverletzung und das
wird bestimmt auch irgendwie geahndet
werden können Herr Koch Herr mich als
die zwei abschließende Punkte einmal die
Widerspiegelung auch ein bisschen der
Diskussion hier bei uns da gibt es viele
Kommentare wie den von Jesus in der
Disco er schreibt bei Youtube es ist als
würden die Spieler auf einem Friedhof
ausgetragen angesichts der zahlreichen
Toten Arbeiter im Gegensatz dazu kommt
dann aber die Frage auf zum Beispiel von
Daniel Wolf errichtet Sie auch direkt an
Sie Herr Michalski finden Sie es richtig
Fußball und Menschenrechte miteinander
zu vermischen wieso denken Sie das
taktisch daran anzuhängen bringt das
etwas oder ist das nicht einfach
rumtaktiererei vielleicht auch wichtig
da noch mal den Aspekt rauszuarbeiten ja
es hat nichts mit Fußball zu tun oder
irgendeiner anderen Sportart eine
Sportart und Menschenrechte zu
verquicken dass das bringt gar nichts
muss man auch nicht aber so wie eine
große Vereinigung dahinter steckt und
die FIFA ist wie ein großer Konzern dann
hat diese Vereinigung dieser Konzern
diese Organisation
internationale Verpflichtung und die
muss er nachkommen und wenn es nicht tun
dann ist es eine Pflichtverletzung und
deswegen fordern wir von der FIFA oder
auch wenn es jetzt keine
Fußballweltmeisterschaft geben würde
sondern Siemens würde da was bauen
würden wir das von Siemens fordern dass
es sich für die Menschenrechte einsetzt
innerhalb ihres Rahmens in dem sie
agiert und das hat die FIFA nicht
gemacht und dann noch eine ab ja oder
Herr kocht gerne noch mal dazu also sie
wissen schon dass die FIFA nichts baut
und günstigen vertragliche Beziehung zu
irgendeinen dieser Bauten hat das ist
ihnen schon klar also ich nehme mir das
Beispiel die Allianz Arena wird gebaut
die wurde umgebaut für die WM und da
wäre jetzt ein Arbeiter gestorben wer
soll da verhaften Gebieter oder FC
Bayern München oder wenn dann Champions
League spielt stattfindet Champions
League das ist mir jetzt nicht so ganz
klar gewesen
alle die für den Bau dieses Stadions
verantwortlich sind und für die Stadien
sind auch sind die Unternehmen selber
die Baufirmen verantwortlich die
katarische Regierung aber eben auch die
FIFA selbst wenn sie nicht direkte
Auftraggeberin für den Einzelnen
Stadionbau ist so ist es doch
im wegen der FIFA dass da überhaupt
gebaut wird
bleiben wir zum Schluss noch mal mit
einem Blick in die Zukunft es gibt ja
eigentlich auch die essentielle Frage
wie umgehen in der Zukunft mit solchen
Situationen mit Sport und
fußballveranstaltungen in autokratisch
geführten Ländern an sie beide die Frage
was würden Sie sich da wünschen Herr
Michalski vielleicht beginnen Sie sie
haben Bedingungen gefordert welche wären
das wer darf im Fußball unter welchen
Bedingungen teilhaben
also Fußball darf jeder teilhaben aber
wenn es um die Vergabe von großen
Großveranstaltungen geht die mit großen
kommerziellen Interesse und mit großen
Bauten verbunden sind dann sollten und
zwar nach den Richtlinien der Vereinten
Nationen die solche Sachen nur vergeben
werden an die Länder die die
Menschenrechte
achten wenn es im Rahmen dieser
Tätigkeit ist also wenn es im Rahmen des
Sports ist also natürlich ist die FIFA
jetzt tatsächlich nicht verantwortlich
dafür dass Frauen unterdrückt werden in
Katar das kann sie auch gar nicht ändern
aber sie muss in ihrem Umfeld in dem sie
tätig ist muss sie dafür achten darauf
achten dass Frauenrechte eben nicht
verletzt werden und da wiederum ist die
Regierung dafür zuständig und wenn die
Regierung nicht willens ist eine
Situation so zu schaffen dass die
Menschenrechte deutlich verletzt werden
dann hat diese Regierung auch nicht
verdient so eine große Show zu bekommen
die sie natürlich auch als eine
propaganda-show missbrauchen kann Herr
Koch zum Schluss zu ihnen eine Position
die sie auch mit Blick auf die Zukunft
teilen und was sind ihre Wünsche
also ich würde mir wünschen dass dieses
Vergabe System geändert wird und dass
man eben anhand dieser Kriterien die man
festlegt dann sagt zum Beispiel zum
Thema Menschenrechte oder Rechte von
Homosexuellen da muss dieses Land dieses
Land das wären bewirbt eben auch
mindestens auf die vier kommen oder ob
oder auf die fünf oder was auch immer
wenn man die Linie zieht und dass man
dann anhand von solchen
Evaluationen Bewerber auch ausschließen
kann das würde ich mir wünschen aber
ihre Frage vorhin ja war ja auch miese
wie realistisch ich das halte dass
dieses System geändert wird dass das
Problem dass eben der Kongress selbst
dazu Stimmen müsste sich zu entmachten
und von daher sehe ich das nicht
unbedingt realistisch
Alexander Koch und wenn sie mich als die
vielen Dank für die Diskussion hier bei
ZDF heute live ganz herzlichen Dank und
noch einen schönen Abend an sie beide
danke genau tschüss
ein Thema über das viel diskutiert wurde
viel diskutiert wird und sicher auch
wenn in 20 Tagen dann der Ball rollt in
Katar wenn dort die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft startet wir
werden darüber weiter berichten auch
weiter diskutieren vielen Dank für heute
und bis zum nächsten Mal macht's gut
tschüss